tengo tres plátanos uno dos tres
plátanos y estos tres plátanos le sumará
algún número
para que yo termine con 10 plátanos aquí
empezamos con 3 y algún número le sumar
e para terminar con 10 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 así que la pregunta es que el número
es de sumarle a estos tres plátanos para
yo llegar a tener 10 plátanos los invito
a que pausa en el vídeo y lo intenten
por su parte
vamos a trabajar juntos en este problema
aquí tenemos tres plátanos lo que
debemos es añadir o sumar plátanos de
tal manera que lleguemos hasta 10 vamos
a empezar a colocar plátanos nuevos si
empiezo con 3 sumar otro y tendremos 4
este será el sexto plátano
y 10 éste será el décimo plátano yo
asume una cantidad de plátanos de este
lado y en total ahora tendremos 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 plátanos entonces la
pregunta es cuántos plátanos sumen para
llegar de 3 a 10 que recuerda 10 es el
número al que queríamos llegar contaré
únicamente los plátanos que sumamos aquí
y los pondré con un color distinto fue
uno
7 plátanos sumen 7 plátanos estos son
los siete plátanos que he sumado a los
tres para que lleguemos a un total de 10
así que podemos decir que 3 más 7 será
igual a 10 y entonces ustedes pueden ver
que lo que tenemos del lado izquierdo
del símbolo de igualdad son exactamente
10 plátanos lo mismo que tenemos del
lado derecho del signo de igualdad 10
plátanos en el lado izquierdo tenemos 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
y del lado derecho de este signo tenemos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
así es que podemos decir que entonces si
son iguales
esto es una igualdad nos vemos en otro
vídeo